take a look at this exclusive atlanta
protesters i love breitbart puts it in
quotes
embedded nails into fireworks leaked fbi
document states
and they show a photo of these
commercial grade mortars they use
and we'll just read it they say
breitbart texas reviewed an fbi activity
alert regarding the use of modified
fireworks during the demonstration in
atlanta
which began on july 25th the alert
states that approximately 100 to 200
people dressed in dark clothing
backpacks goggles and helmets
approached the ice office in atlanta the
subjects reportedly carried shields bats
and large sticks
following the attack that left 20 broken
windows bomb technicians discovered
commercial-grade fireworks with nails
embedded in the mortar shell
the document reads images of the
modified fireworks show multiple large
nails embedded in the devices
organizers called on people to come out
in solidarity
with the quote freedom fighter freedom
fighters of
portland breitbart texas reported a
video tweeted from atlanta excuse me
shows multiple fireworks exploding
around the doors and windows
now look i'm in there they're
they're speechless i i didn't see that
before you showed me that and that's
crazy
the nails being embedded in them yeah
that's so you can see right here right
there they're pressed
into it yep that's in crazy in portland
there was a report this is from the new
york post i believe that one officer got
impaled in the hand
because antifa had been laying nails out
so they like grabbed for something and
then got a nail through the hand
something like that happened
yeah and people uh some of the cops got
burned covered in welts
there's one photo that was talking about
the injuries and it looks like one of
the officers
was a bike officer okay and he got a
gash
on his calf which you can see it like it
looks like a bike injury
and so the tweet said something like
officers were injured this that and this
and they show an image of the officer
with the injury from his bike and then
people are like they're
they're lying he didn't really get
injured by the protesters he got injured
by his bike
and i'm like that's the stupidest thing
i've ever heard you know why if a police
officer is riding his bike
and a bunch of crazy leftists start
throwing things and attacking him and he
slips and gets injured on his bike
it's not his fault he didn't just fall
off his bike randomly he was attacked by
people yeah
so if they're showing you a photo of a
fight between far leftists and cops
and a cop falls off his bike and gets
injured and they show you that
why why does it matter if it's like he
fell off his bike you made him fall off
his bike
oh man you're right yeah that's crazy oh
you want to show the
yeah i pulled that up because i don't
well i don't think we can actually play
the video on youtube to be honest
oh yeah well well we could just talk
about it so so this is actually
um from last night andy noe is great he
he's covering all sorts of
um on the ground stuff you know he's got
all his different sources that he passes
along to the the public eye because he's
got a platform for it so this this one
here is
specifically um a bomb was pl i i say
bomb because
it was a bomb it was def yeah definitely
okay yeah it was definitely a bomb it
was something significantly bigger than
a mortar
it wasn't fireworks it was clearly it is
a boom
it sounded kind of like a giant fireball
grenade
you know it wasn't it wasn't fireworks
it was an ied you're right absolutely
right yeah
so yeah i don't know how to go find it
on on his page well look i also
retweeted this
and it's it's crazy they're clearly yeah
you can we'll probably get in trouble
for doing justice i kid you not
really why yeah why let's just play it
whatever
you guys ready just play it
[Music]
yeah that's serious that's not fireworks
that's that wasn't that wasn't fireworks
then yes no this is this is definitely
some they're they're elevating what
they're doing they're they're clearly
really trying to get into this
courthouse for some whatever reason it
is it's
it's insane i think the intention for a
lot of the
the explosives they're making is to
start fires you can see that after it
goes off
fire kind of goes up the side of the
building for for a little bit before
going out
and they've been trying to burn the
building for quite some time
so that didn't look like it was meant to
cause shock damage by like an explosion
yeah but to like blast the fireball out
i don't know exactly what their
intention is or what kind of bomb that
was but that was not a commercial-grade
firework that was literally an ied
when people say they use fireworks as
ieds
okay that was them literally making a
bomb yeah that was not fireworks
they so according to i think bill barr
may have mentioned this
using water balloons full of kerosene or
some kind of
fuel so that when they throw the
balloons and it splatters the fireworks
might ignite it
or the other way around that they could
start small fires and then they throw
the balloons it's fuel in the fire and
it sprays everywhere
that's what i think all those mason jars
that were set two nights ago
they were finding all these mason jars
around the fence but they weren't
they didn't have like a rag in them like
a molotov cocktail but they were filled
with some sort of liquid
i think that's what it was yeah you know
kerosene or something well and it would
hurt
you know a glass jar filled with water
like a mason jar filled with
sealed with water that's fairly heavy oh
you throw that out of someone that can
hurt
you know especially if it's flammable
and these people
are they they need to be stopped like
and people need to see that this is
actually what's going on
at night yep people don't believe it
yeah
nether well no that that's uh that
they're lying that's a rumor that's only
being spread here in dc
like myth get out of here man i think
there's footage myself
the there's there's no circumstance in
which i will be happy with their answer
to this other than condemning
if they come out and say it's not true
there's no violence
yeah then they're either lying and and
essentially protecting these people or
they're so insanely inept
they should not be in office but i'll
tell you what man watching that bill bar
hearing was like
man i i can't i i'm just
i'm flabbergasted at how bad the
democrats have become you know you know
when you're watching
a press conference like a white house
press conference and you got
the way that the reporters ask questions
specifically
they're not good questions they're all
round about trying to like get the
president or
uh mckennedy to say something you know
what they're they're trying to fish for
the right thing sound bites
yeah it felt like that's what the
democrats were doing but they're
terrible at it
they were they had someone someone speak
yeah they never let him speak
you know it was just like what i don't
understand what
their goal was re-election well they
they were specific to
a amount of time and they were probably
stressing because
he was trying to answer the question and
if he if he did answer any of their
questions they would run out of time
and every single time they were oh your
time's up well i just need to
add this one like gotcha sentence to
to bill barr like yeah and take that and
i'm out of here
or i'm gonna add this really weird uh
evidence second week of october in all
of their districts there's gonna be
commercials and it's gonna be like
you know democrat number one challenged
bill barr
on being corrupt and protecting donald
trump
and to show them going like no you are
corrupt
that's what it's all about and then
they're getting their his response was
i will always choose the law i will
always pick the law over anything else
and i was just like yes that's that's
what i want as my attorney general
someone who's going to choose the law
period period done well so the the funny
thing about the the
the roger stone stuff okay was that he
recommended a light a
lesser sentence because stone was 67
okay and they attacked him for it and
i'm like that's actually
i really like that he did that
regardless of guilt like
you know sending recommendations
proportional to the individual
i like i don't like a robotic system
where it's like you agree
we don't care who you are or what your
circumstances are we're throwing you in
the cannon not going to think twice
yeah why would they want that do you
want a system they're fighting against
that kind of thing
no they're they're not they're fighting
for re-election
but i'll tell you what they're fighting
for right here check this out
mayor ted wheeler uh oh the mask slipped
oh boy
fell off the antifa mask commissioner
joanne pdx and i
are calling for an immediate meeting
with department of homeland security
leadership on the ground in portland
and with acting secretary dhs wolf to
discuss
a ceasefire and the removal of
heightened federal forces from portland
wait wait hold on how does he have the
authority to negotiate a ceasefire on
behalf of antifa
i thought they were in a group
if there's a large amount of leftists
that are violent
how is how is the mayor going to
negotiate in their behalf
does he have some sort of control over
this group either
directly or indirectly say with the
police is he basically saying he can go
to the feds and say we're going to stop
fighting you and we'll put it all to
rest if you
and i'll tell you what he's saying
removal of heightened federal forces
from portland
he's basically saying get rid of the
extra guys you've sent
in you know the heightened forces keep
keep the the marshals
and we will stop what does that mean
about which side he's on
i've been saying this it's a de facto
letter of mark these far leftists are
working
essentially at the behest whether they
realize it or not for the portland and
oregon government
i think so attacking the federal
government at the very least
what mayor wheeler is saying is that he
could crush this
protest this riot at any moment with the
police
but he's choosing not to or he's just
you know
talking nonsense making it all up and he
has no authority what is
in that courthouse that they want what
is it
what's in there that's the only victory
either it's a symbolic thing
to take down the federal courthouse or
there's something in there
that they want taken out i know it's a
conspiracy but
and makes me think i think it's it's not
it's not even
necessarily a conspiracy they would love
to destroy as much as possible in that
federal courthouse
it would result in tons of people being
released from prison having their cases
dropped
and they know it yep that's true i mean
look it's a federal courthouse there's
probably
a lot i'll just i'll say that a lot of
cases that go through there
and what all gone
i think for the most part symbolic
victory but the bigger issue i have is
when the when we talk about the
democratic governors and mayors
marching with black lives matter
allowing them in the face of the
lockdowns
it's obvious they're aligned with them
right yep then when the mayor of
portland
joins them it's like okay now hold on a
minute he's he's standing there and
they're throwing explosives
yeah he's got to know what's going on no
he claims you know oh i'm just i'm you
know i'm just out here
then he's like i'm working for you guys
now he's actually saying we'll negotiate
a ceasefire
okay this guy's been running the whole
thing from the get-go i'm sorry yeah so
either either antifa
is a group that has it is organized that
you can actually talk to
which is what he's implying here or
they're not
or they're a figment of everyone's
imagination make up your mind democrats
please the american public is not as
stupid as you
keep thinking they are and they're
they're fed up
i know i am yeah how was he gonna
he could be lying you know just trying
to trying to con trick the feds into
leaving
even though he has no control over the
far left at all i think the more
worrying thing is that
like i mentioned they're trying to wield
the far left to their advantage
and they think they're doing it but then
something changed
public sentiment around the riot started
to backfire on the democrats and now all
of a sudden he's asking for a ceasefire
yeah he's like oh man this this is
starting to backfire we we need to
uh backstab it's funny because i keep
hearing from people like i posted some
photos on instagram
there are a lot of photos you can see of
storefronts that have signs saying
please don't hurt us
because the far left goes around
destroying business the cops aren't the
ones going around smashing out people's
windows
nope so it's they're begging the the
live desk just to leave them alone
and this is really really bad for the
narrative when people in the suburbs see
those messages they get scared like i
don't want to live that way i don't want
these people coming to my
my place yeah i see comments from people
saying you know i live in portland
and you're wrong everything's fine and
you know what i do when i see these
comments
nothing you know why why because a
minute later another another comment
pops up from someone saying i live in
portland and you're lying we're sick of
it
yeah our businesses are suffering nobody
wants to go downtown anymore kovit has
locked everything down now the protests
are making it worse
everybody wants to get on with their
lives stop acting like you know
yeah and then they argue and i'm like
listen
the fact that they're arguing proves
there is a problem
you might like the riots you might say
it's no big deal we're fighting
injustice
doesn't matter the fact that one person
was that guy's name philip
yep phillip anderson philip anderson
would come out and be like no stop
you're making everything worse
says enough yep when the silent majority
when when even a small handful of
normies are forced out on the street to
stop this
that's how you know you've really
started shaking up the beast the far
leftists always want to go out with
bricks they always want to smash
everything up
regular people want to hang out and play
video games and order pizza and
just get on with their day and figure
out how to get through this this
trying time when they start showing up
you're waking up that beast
that that sleeping that sleeping giant
oh yeah who's like
we did not want to have to do this you
forced us yeah the term
silent majority is is not even accurate
it's the sleeping giants that are
that work that they that they're the
backbone of america they're the ones
doing the hard work
keeping our civilization going our
society what
what we are what we have in this country
they protect us while we sleep
yeah absolutely club quote sure regular
people who are doing these jobs
yeah so now they're being they're
they're being forced
to stand up and many of them probably
didn't want to do it
yep i agree but this is how is how bad
things have been getting
that i i just when it comes back to the
polls and everything i just don't
believe it
no not same i don't agree yeah i don't
believe it at all
but maybe maybe we're uh unfortunately
the only people
who pay attention you know the people
who are watching this
look it's it's it's amazing that we get
you know you guys come and hang out with
us
there's so many people watching and
listening but come on man cnn
gets like 300 million views on youtube
every month 300 million
okay well they're also they're also in
like all over the place is it all only
americans no
you know cnn is one of the new there's
in every airport right but there's
an international to separate like sure
okay
so i just mean like cnn does look people
want to make fun of them because their
ratings have been going down but they
they get ratings and you combine that
with all of their outlets that are lying
nonstop
yeah and it's worrying maybe we're in
this bubble of people who are
arguing you know even arguing about some
of these ideas and and thinking
critically
and and look man i try and watch some of
these leftist youtubers
okay and i'm just left stunned by like
you can't do it the ineptitude the lack
of sourcing right exactly
whenever i do uh all of my segments on
my other channels tim cast and tim cast
news on youtube
we do exactly i do exactly the same
thing we do here where when we're
talking about something you can see the
source however on my channels
the source is displayed 100 of the time
there's no cutaway to my face or anyone
else's face
and the reason for that is i want
everyone to have it right in front of
them
i'm not just saying these things here's
cnn the new york times and msnbc all
saying this thing
yeah and i'm going to tell you how i
feel and i'm going to show you sources
and go to the root of where this
information came from i watched some of
these other channels
and i'm like did did you bother google
searching this
right there was one instant instant uh
instance where i think it was ted cruz
was asked by
chuck todd on meet the press do you
believe that ukraine meddled
in the 2016 election and ted cruz's
response was something
like i think the media
we've seen it from the new york times to
you know uh forbes and several other
outlets that
yes there were ukrainians who are
seeking to interfere in the election
and then on the on the msnbc side you
hear laughing
i think it was out everyone starts
laughing yeah and there's a there was a
certain you know leftist youtuber who
did a segment on it
and then just immediately started
laughing and he was like wow how dumb is
ted cruz they're laughing at him
and i was like and this is a prominent
you know youtuber and i was like i face
palmed
and i was like i heard what ted cruz
said i google-searched what he said and
guess what
he was right there was a bunch of
stories from forbes the new york times
the hill
saying that yes there were ukrainians
who were trying to interfere in the
election
not that it was a systemic top-down
attack like it was with russia
but there were ukrainians who had vested
interest in trying to help
hillary clinton win and that's a fact
the new york times
has a story to say ukrainian court ruled
that these people in ukraine were trying
to meddle in our election
but chuck todd meet the press supposed
to be this prestigious news outlet was
laughing
did chuck todd does he not have the
internet maybe not they don't do
any research thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you